[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est science public votre
rendez-vous de débat et de reportage 90
minutes pour donner du sens à
l'actualité grâce à nos experts en étant
ensemble tous les soirs du lundi au
jeudi pour 90 minutes à 18h et à 22h et
notre premier titre c'est cette bombe à
retardement sont les propos du président
du Medef et des professionnels de
l'immobilier la crise du logement a de
lourdes conséquences économiques et
sociales notamment pour les plus démunis
comme ici à Marseille on a du mal à se
loger bien évidemment parce que les prix
sont en train de monter en flèche de
grimper on a du mal à se loger parce que
l'offre de logement quelle qu'elle soit
des loyers les plus faibles aux maisons
les plus correctes et d'une offre de
plus en plus restreinte des logements
sociaux à la construction dans le neuf
en passant par les prêts à taux zéro la
première ministre a annoncé aujourd'hui
un plan de relance du secteur est-il à
la hauteur des enjeux pourquoi cette
crise pourrait alimenter pour longtemps
la colère des classes moyennes en en
débat juste après ces titres et puis
notre débat de société il portera ce
soir sur la transidentité des mineurs le
parti LR au Sénat vient de lancer un
groupe de travail sur la hausse
croissante des demandes de changement de
sexe chez les enfants et surtout les
adolescents qu'elle est l'ampleur du
phénomène les bloqueurs d'hormones que
prennent certains ados sont-ils
dangereux pour la santé les associations
de défense de la transidentité
sont-elles trop offensives auprès des
plus jeunes au répondra à toutes ces
questions et on tentera de faire le tri
entre les fantasmes et la réalité dans
45 minutes mais d'abord l'actualité de
ce 5 juin c'est donc ce plan de relance
du logement annoncé par Elisabeth borne
à l'issue du Conseil national de la
refondation Cécile Siksou pas de mesure
choc mais des dispositions techniques
avec son plan le gouvernement compte des
amorcer la crise du logement il y a un
risque de bombes sociales le logement
c'est un espèce d'Eldorado pour beaucoup
de nos concitoyens et moi ma mission
avec tous les acteurs du logement c'est
empêcher que cette bombe explose et donc
trouver des solutions pour permettre à
nos concitoyens de se loger premier
objectif du gouvernement faciliter
l'accès à la propriété parmi les mesures
par annoncées la révision mensuelle
plutôt que trimestrielle du taux d'usure
elle est prolongée jusque fin 2023 ce
taux maximal auquel une banque a le
droit de prêter et souvent source de
blocage pour de futurs acquéreurs autre
mesure en direction des propriétaires le
prolongement du prêt à taux zéro
jusqu'en 2027 mais il ne sera plus
applicable pour les maisons neuves une
déception pour les professionnels du
bâtiment le prêt à taux zéro déjà pour
aider nos primo-accédants à nos jeunes
ménages acquérir en logement pour la
première fois ben celui-là il est
supprimé donc oui première grosse
déception 80% des Français veulent avoir
veulent acquérir un logement individuel
une maison individuelle côté locataire
le plan prévoit l'extension de la
garantie visale de millions de personnes
pourraient bénéficier de cette caution
pour les loyers contre un million
actuellement le gouvernement prévoit
également l'arrêt du dispositif Pinel
fin 2024 jugée
inefficace il prévoit des avantages
fiscaux pour les investisseurs locatifs
pas de mesure en revanche sur les
locations de courte durée type Airbnb ce
que déplore la sénatrice socialiste
marine-noëlle linmann
comme si il y a pas de problème
je me demande qui protège quoi enfin
vous dire quel est l'intérêt de la
France de laisser exploser le Airbnb
dans les centres villes pendant qu'on
n'arrive pas à éloger nos concitoyens
alors un peu un peu d'Airbnb sous la oui
mais enfin ça devient maintenant à
marcher substitutif au logement des
Français le gouvernement prévoit
également de passer un pacte avec les
bailleurs sociaux pour rénover le park
existant et produire de nouveaux
logements sociaux pour réagir à ces
annonces j'accueille Pascal et belle
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes économiste
spécialisé dans l'anticipation du
comportement des consommateurs
directrices associés chez seways Henri
busikazo bonsoir bienvenue aussi
président de l'Institut du management
des services immobiliers membres du
Conseil national de leur formation
consacrée à ce thème du logement et
membre du Conseil national de l'habitat
David Amiel bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes députés renaissance de Paris
et Mathieu croissanto utorise politique
bonsoir Mathieu peut-être un premier
constat parce qu'elle est belle à quel
point parce que on va vraiment
s'intéresser à l'effet économique et
social aussi de cette crise de logement
à quel point ça devient une
préoccupation majeure des Français le
logement alors vraiment le sujet du
logement c'est vraiment ce qui pénalise
le plus les français puisque en termes
de comparatif européen le poids du
logement on est le pays où c'est le plus
élevé juste derrière la Slovénie et ça
fait très longtemps que c'est le cas
c'est à dire que dans notre pays le
poids des dépenses de logement dans les
dépenses de consommation n'a fait que
croître il y a qu'au Royaume-Uni ou sa
croix autant et ça s'est accru avec la
crise du covid parce qu'on n'a pas assez
de logement qui ont été construits on a
une population qui croit notamment le
nombre de ménages qui continuent à
croître puisqu'on a de plus en plus de
divorces de séparation qui font qu'en
effet par rapport à d'autres pays on a
cette croissance qui qui fait qu'il
faudrait en construire beaucoup plus
donc il y a vraiment ce poids du
logement qui finalement va se reporter
sur d'autres secteurs en fait on a
aujourd'hui une tension très forte du
côté de l'aide alimentaire
et se dévast communicants c'est-à-dire
parce qu'il y a pas de logement et que
finalement ça coûte trop cher on est
obligé d'aller vers l'aide alimentaire
et finalement ça se reporte vers un
autre secteur et donc il y a vraiment
une une contrainte qui va être beaucoup
plus faible d'ailleurs sur le loyer chez
les très jeunes en fait c'est que les
jeunes générations aujourd'hui un poids
du logement beaucoup plus important que
les générations les plus anciennes et ça
s'est accru en termes d'inégalité
l'Insee montre bien qu'on a aujourd'hui
17 points de différence entre les plus
riches et les plus modestes sur le poids
du logement c'était que 2%, il y a 40
ans alors ça c'est vraiment une
inégalité un facteur d'inégalité qui
s'accroît effectivement cet effet domino
on va plusieurs fois en parler on pourra
parler aussi par exemple de des liens
entre la crise du logement et le marché
de l'emploi parce que c'est évidemment
pas neutre non plus Henri buzeaucazeau
on vient d'entendre l'essentiel des
mesures annoncées par la première
ministre est-ce qu'elle vous semble à la
hauteur des enjeux de cette crise dont
parle en l'état non alors il nous a été
dit au CNR David Daniel était aussi que
le CNR allait continuer ses travaux et
que cette séance dite conclusive c'est
écrit sur le pupitre ou aller s'exprimer
la première ministre ne le serait pas il
n'est pas abouti il est très
incantatoire sur un certain nombre de
postes les bons tiroirs ont été
identifiés le foncier le soutien
logement social à la rénovation etc
les leviers ont été vus mais on voit des
verbes tels que ouvrir la réflexion sur
réfléchir à voilà donc assez tard alors
on a pris du retard on peut s'étonner
que après de multiples rapports qui ont
été commandés par les gouvernements on
peut penser au rapport rabzamen il y a
quelques mois pour ainsi dire un deux
tomes sur la construction le CNR qui a
rendu en fait il y a deux mois au
gouvernement c'est ses conclusions elles
étaient présentées aujourd'hui un peu
selon en allemand tout ça c'est censé
éclairer il y a de nombreuses solutions
préconisées qui n'ont pas été retenues
je dis bien en l'état je pense que les
parlementaires vont travailler mais
aujourd'hui il y a deux mesures
concrètes pour ainsi dire c'est le
rachat aux promoteurs des programmes
plantés comme on dit par la Caisse des
Dépôts par Action Logement bon ça c'est
une mesure sauvetage de l'appareil de
production c'est pas une mesure
politique de genre et puis le prêt à
taux zéro qui est prolongé je dirais un
minima il manque de souffle ce qui a été
dit il est supprimé pas supprimer il est
modifié
on y reviendra là dessus David Amiens
est-ce qu'il y a plus d'argent dans les
caisses pour financer un plan de relance
du logement à la hauteur des enjeux non
mais d'abord ça a été dit ça a été
également rappelé par le ministre
Olivier Klein en introduction du Conseil
national de la refondation aujourd'hui
c'est une étape donc il y a beaucoup de
mesures très utiles qui ont été
annoncées on aura l'occasion d'y revenir
je pense dans le débat mais c'est
évident que ce n'est pas en une seule
fois qu'on va résoudre la crise du
logement parce que cette crise du
logement on la traîne depuis très
longtemps en quelque sorte c'est une
crise en poupée russe vous avez une
crise que le long terme et celle de
l'aménagement du territoire dans notre
pays depuis 40 ans on a des activités
économiques des services publics qui se
concentrent dans les métropoles où se
concentre donc le désir aussi d'habiter
de beaucoup de nos concitoyens des prix
qui explosent et beaucoup de Français
qui sont relégués éloignés avec des
dépenses de carburant important des
trajets domicile travail très long c'est
une différence temple avec des pays
comme l'Allemagne beaucoup plus
décentralisée vous avez une crise de
moyen terme qui est qu'on ne construit
pas assez de logements en France en tout
cas qu'on ne construit pas assez dans
les zones où on en a besoin c'est lié à
la rareté du foncier au fait que
certaines collectivités locales ne
donnent pas aussi assez de permis de
construire c'est lié à un certain nombre
de procédures c'est lié aussi l'immense
chantier qu'on a devant nous de la
rénovation thermique et puis vous avez
une crise de court terme qui est celle
pour le coup liée à l'augmentation des
taux d'intérêt depuis à peu près un an
qui fait que beaucoup de Français des
classes populaires et donc quand il y a
autant de crise en poupées russes comme
vous dites l'enjeu de dans une situation
d'urgence peut-être que c'est là que il
fallait peut-être taper plus fort
raison pour laquelle aujourd'hui il y
avait d'abord un enjeu de répondre à la
crise la plus urgente il essaie de crise
de la demande qu'on voit depuis un an et
en ce sens il y a quand même un certain
nombre de mesures importantes qui ont
été annoncés pour les acheteurs
particuliers il y a la prolongation du
prêt à tosero qui devait s'arrêter
prochainement qui va désormais être
prolongé jusqu'en 2027 on va avoir un
programme de rachat de logements aussi
par la Caisse des dépôts et
consignations par Action Logement de
près de 50 000 logements là aussi ça va
permettre de sortir des projets de terre
et d'éviter d'avoir un effondrement de
la construction parce que sinon je vais
vous redonne également je vais vous
redonner le soutien la demande parce que
s'il y avait pas eu ce rachat il y a
tout simplement des sociétés qui
mettaient la clé sous la porte c'est
c'était quoi le fait de production et
l'appareil de service aujourd'hui est
entamé on va être très clair le
président de la Fédération du Bâtiment
c'est la FFB observe ça très
minutieusement annonce si aucune mesure
assez forte n'est décidé de la place à
hauteur de 100 000 emplois dans les 24 à
36 mois ça c'est l'amont la valse et la
commercialisation aujourd'hui les
négociateurs les agences immobilières il
y a un record de dépôt de bilan dans ce
cette activité là les commercialisateurs
de logement neuf bref aujourd'hui on a
un péril sur allez on va dire près de
200000 personnes alors il est évident
que ce qui est fait là pour sauvegarder
les promoteurs les entreprises en
bâtiment derrière qui ne sont pas payés
quand un promoteur ne commercialise pas
toute cette chaîne là ce qui est décidé
il faut il faut le saluer c'est puissant
voilà ça ne règle pas la suite c'est à
dire comme promoteur qui va être sauvé
seulement n'est pas assez forte si elle
est pas assez solvabilisée il y a des
mesures sur le crédit mais on attend de
voir ce qu'elles vont donner notamment
au Conseil de stabilité financière à ce
moment-là les promoteurs ne remettront
pas en chantier ça veut dire qu'ils ne
feront pas de logement privé ni de
logement sociaux je rappelle que ils
sont des contributeurs à plus de 50% à
la production sociale aussi et donc ça
fait dire au président du Medef Geoffroy
que on est face à une bombe à
retardement à l'écoute je signale quand
même un problème de logement on va au
devant c'est une bombe à retardement la
construction neuve donc logement neuf
est en train de ralentir à toute vitesse
l'année 23 et l'année 24 va être
catastrophique parce qu'elle est ce que
vous employez ce terme vous aussi bon
bah retardement oui tout à fait parce
qu'en effet la hausse des taux d'intérêt
à accrue la crise qui était déjà là en
fait on en parlait pas mais c'était déjà
présent notamment parce qu'il y a
finalement ce budget ce poids du budget
qui est très important on a des
différences entre les différentes
catégories des populations qui en effet
ne peuvent pas bouger en effet je crois
qu'on a un problème en France avec ce
modèle où on a les deux tiers des
Français qui sont propriétaires en
Allemagne c'est que la moitié et en fait
de ne pas demander à des millions de
Français
c'est qu'il y a des c'est que ce soit
des institutions en fait qui soit
propriétaire il y a une étude de l'INSEE
qui vient de montrer que du côté des
particuliers il y a trois et demi pour
cent des propriétaires qui détiennent
68% des logements en fait c'est que
c'est concentré par des gens qui ont
plus de 5 logements et en fait quand
c'est un particulier qui possède un
logement la seule chose qui veut c'est
de la rentabilité donc il fait pas la
rénovation énergétique et donc il y a
des hausses de loyer qui sont pas assez
encadrés et qui font que les loyers sont
très élevés donc on voit bien qu'il y a
un sujet qui est très important on sent
que c'est en effet une crise de fond une
crise structurelle et donc là pour
l'instant évidemment on commence par ce
qui est le plus évident mais il va
falloir quand même essayer de modifier
un modèle politique différent de
logement j'allais dire idéologique mais
pas de la rénovation énergétique on est
bien obligé d'avoir des gens qui sont
solides pour investir et faire cette
rénovation ce qui me frappe c'est qu'on
découvre pas le problème on va quand
même un ministre du Logement qui dit il
y a une bombe sociale ça fait des
décennies que la part du logement dans
le budget des ménages augmente de façon
inconscient
on a un président Macron nouvellement
élu en 2017 qui avait promis un choc
d'offres ma mémoire est bonne tout à
fait qu'est-ce qui s'est passé depuis 6
ans
ensuite ce qui s'est passé depuis 6 ans
c'est que les actions très fortes je
pense notamment à la lutte contre le
sans-abrisme on a eu 440 000 personnes
qui ont été sorties de l'hébergement
d'urgence on a eu des dispositifs très
importants je pense notamment aux jeunes
aux étudiants qui ne parviennent pas à
se louer qui bénéficie maintenant de la
garantie visale c'est-à-dire la garantie
de ceux qui n'ont pas leurs parents ou
des membres de leur famille qui peuvent
se porter caution au moment de louer ça
fait d'ailleurs partie des objectifs
aujourd'hui de passer de 1 million à 2
millions on a effectivement simplifié un
grand nombre de procédures on va
continuer sur la rénovation écologique
il y a eu des pas très importants
mais ce qui est très important c'est
qu'effectivement c'est une action
collective pour répondre à la crise du
logement
nous interrompre parce qu'elle est belle
dit c'est presque un système qu'il faut
réinventer dans sa dans sa logique qui
est propriétaire est-ce qu'il faut que
ce soit des institutions qui soient
propriétaires parce qu'elles sont plus
solides alors moi je le prendrai pas
sous cet angle là ça fait partie des
débats évidemment qu'on peut avoir là où
je suis convaincu qu'il y a un système
devant nous à réinventer c'est aussi à
l'aune de la transition écologique si on
se projette dans les 10 ans à venir on
va en parler parce que cette grande
politique d'aménagement du territoire un
peu comme on avait eu dans les trente
glorieuses pour l'air industriel on va
devoir penser l'aménagement du
territoire donc le logement donc
l'habitat à l'heure de la transition
écologique ce qui pose des questions sur
le transport sur l'industrie sur le
logement sur la rénovation écologique on
aura je pense l'occasion avec vous mais
j'ai peut-être le sentiment que ça
complique encore l'équation avec les
passoires thermiques avec le 0
artificialisation net tout ça ce sont
des enjeux majeurs de la transformation
environnementale mais qui complique le
métier les professionnels de
l'immobilier je propose à Steve Jourdain
de nous rejoindre peut-être pour aller
un peu plus loin bonsoir Steve sur le
constat on a commencé à le faire mais
vous allez le détailler avec pas mal de
de chiffres donc secteur entré en crise
et les Français comptent de plus en plus
de mal se loger oui et quand il le
peuvent ça leur coûte de plus en plus
cher il faut savoir que le logement est
le premier poste de dépenses des
Français on va voir ce chiffre
19,7% comme le taux des forces
c'est-à-dire le rapport entre la somme
de dépenses liée à la résidence
principale et les revenus des ménages ce
taux grimpent même jusqu'à 32% pour les
Français les plus pauvres il a pris 2,3
points en 12 ans entre 2001 et 2013 date
de la dernière étude à réaliser par
l'INSEE sur la question se loger donc un
effort de plus en plus important mais de
venir propriétaire voilà aujourd'hui de
la vraie galère on assiste à une
explosion des refus de prêt immobilier
par les banques le nombre d'emprunteurs
qui voient leurs dossiers refuser et
passer Thomas de 30% en janvier des mai
2021 à 45% en mars 2023 c'est presque un
emprunteur sur deux qui est aujourd'hui
recalé par les banques et alors là ça
s'explique évidemment par un contexte
plus général oui on assiste à une baisse
spectaculaire de l'accès au crédit les
taux d'intérêt sont passés de 1,06% en
moyenne en décembre 2021 à 3,28% au mois
de mai très concrètement en 2021 avec un
taux à 1% sur 20 ans pour 200000 euros
empruntés j'avais besoin de présenter à
mon banquier un revenu mensuel net de
2790 euros aujourd'hui avec un taux
d'intérêt à 3,2 je dois gagner 3380
euros net mensuels il me fait donc
toucher 20% de plus qu'il y a deux ans
pour obtenir un même prêt vous avez
vraiment pris votre dossier personnel
pour préparer
malheureusement bon je rigolais la
hausse des taux d'intérêt qui est un
élément de cette crise logement on l'a
évoqué mais il y a aussi une crise de
l'offre oui la chute de la construction
de nos logements continuent il n'y a pas
assez de bien disponible et pourtant le
marché ralenti sur les 11 derniers mois
3359 200 chantiers de nouveaux logements
ont été lancés c'est 8% de moins par
rapport à l'année par rapport à l'année
2021 en 2022 ce qui est pointé du doigt
par les professionnels pour expliquer le
phénomène c'est la hausse des coûts de
construction
[Musique]
les derniers chiffres sur les demandes
en logements social ça s'explique plus
personne veut bouger quoi c'est c'est un
peu ça la difficulté quand on n'a jamais
vu autant
de 2,42 millions de demandes de
logements sociaux on n'a jamais eu une
demande aussi forte je pense qu'il y a
quand même eu un retard pendant le covid
on n'a pas construit ce qui était
premier en terme de logements sociaux et
en effet quand on est dans un logement
social on reste où on est parce que il y
a pas d'autres offres même si on est
éligible à se partir du logement social
pour aller vers le privé
David Amiel vous avez signé une tribune
c'est dans les échos je crois sur ce
thème du logement vous dites cette crise
est une machine à alimenter la colère
des classes moyennes elle s'applique les
grandes promesses de la République le
constat on est tous en train de le faire
sur ce plateau mais je reviens à la
question de la de la hauteur de la
réponse quoi vous voyez ce que je veux
dire si c'est aussi majeur comme comme
enjeu pourquoi voilà on n'a pas mis un
plan plus ambitieux sur la table on a
parlé depuis le début de cette émission
beaucoup de l'urgence économique et on
de revenir mais c'est aussi vous le
dites c'est une urgence sociale
notamment parce qu'on a beaucoup de
Français de la classe moyenne d'ailleurs
les chiffres que vous donniez sur le
logement social sont assez emblématiques
de ça qui au fond n'arrivent pas à avoir
accès au logement social parce que les
files d'attentes sont trop longues et
qui pour autant ne parviennent plus à se
loger dans le parc privé donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle il y a un certain
nombre d'annonces aujourd'hui à
destination précisément de ces classes
moyennes
et solidaires c'est-à-dire ce dispositif
qui permet d'acheter votre logement tout
en levant en quelque sorte la propriété
du terrain sert de diviser par deux
concrètement le prix du logement auquel
vous pouvez acheter c'est un moyen
important c'est une forme un peu
nouvelle de propriété que dans beaucoup
de collectivités locales expérimentent
c'est la question de la garantie visale
très importante pour beaucoup de
salariés beaucoup de travailleurs qui ne
parviennent pas à louer parce qu'on leur
demande trois fois le montant en salaire
trois fois le montant de leur loyer ou
bien des garanties familiales qui ne
peuvent pas avoir on va les tendre c'est
la question aussi du logement
intermédiaire qui est très important je
crois qu'entre le logement privé et le
logement social il faut stimule le
logement intermédiaire et aujourd'hui on
a eu beaucoup d'annonces en faveur du
logement intermédiaire que ce soit le
nombre de zones dans lesquelles il peut
intervenir le type de logement qui peut
racheter et là aussi je crois que ça
fait partie des réponses justement qui
doivent contribuer à répondre à cette
crise des classes moyennes bien sûr que
aujourd'hui c'était une étape ce n'est
pas du tout entendu que c'était pas
conclusif contrairement à ce qui était
écrit sur le sur le pupitre de la
première ministre Henri musicazo sur
cette question des classes moyennes
est-ce que j'en ai bien compris vous
étiez pas sur la même lecture du plan
annoncé par le par le gouvernement
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui manque tiens
pour vous juste une chose le pire toutes
les enquêtes qu'on peut citer sur les
taux d'efforts sur la difficulté à se
loger c'est cette conviction
des Français aujourd'hui que leurs
enfants leurs petits-enfants seront
déclassés en matière de logement par
rapport à eux et ça c'est terrible dans
une république ce qu'il y a de pire
c'est c'est la fin de l'espoir on veut
tous mieux pour nos enfants mais là
c'est on l'attend même pas et c'est
typique de ce moment ça fait plusieurs
années ça va croissant voilà ça monte et
aujourd'hui c'est flagrant et c'est
douloureux dans les classes moyennes
c'est à dire voilà 80% des Français on
va dire
les solutions je dirais vont s'ajouter
les unes aux autres certaines sont allés
un peu interstitielles le bagel
solidaire c'est ingénierie qui fait
qu'on va découper le foncier du bâti
c'est intelligent il faut le booster
transformer les bureaux en logements
c'est une solution surélevé densifier
tout de même il va quand même falloir
que on fasse repartir les les gros
bataillons il y a deux choses qu'il faut
faire il faut que la construction
évidemment reparte on va finir cette
année à peu près à 300 000 logements
neuf je suis entré dans ce secteur ça ne
me rajeunit pas mais ça me permet d'en
arriver il y a 35 ans et bien au début
des années 90 on construit dans ce pays
300000 logements mais il avait 18
millions d'habitants de moins la
mobilité n'était pas la même la
structure des ménages n'était pas la
même on ne se séparait pas autant on ne
décohabitait pas autant
donc c'est évidemment un cancer il faut
faire repartir cette construction pour
arriver sans doute à 400000 à 450000 et
pour ça il faut travailler sur le
foncier un choc d'offre foncière ça n'a
pas été fait ni le président Macron ni
c'est prédécesseur
en plus sur le foncier quand on dit il
faut obliger le foncier public de l'État
mais il y a le foncier public des
collectivités locales il y a aussi
c'était une mesure proposée par le CNR
inverser la fiscalité pour que les
propriétaires privées comme vous ou moi
de terrain soit incités à les vendre et
non pas les théoriser c'est-à-dire que
la taxation de la plus-value sanctionne
la conservation et ça on aurait on
aurait dit au président Macron que c'est
encore le président des riches il avait
pris une mesure comme celle-là alors non
non je crois au contraire que le
président Macron ce qui ne peut que
souhaitait il avait annoncé un choc
d'offre en effet ensuite on a pas parlé
parce que ça n'a pas fonctionné mais il
aime bien le mot choc il parle de choc
de simplification ça non plus ça a pas
été fait il le dit aujourd'hui il faut
simplifier avec ce de construire sur
chaque promoteur qui construit vous ne
savez peut-être pas qu'il y a 5000 norme
qui pèsent aujourd'hui
un tiers venant de la Communauté
européenne deux tiers venant de la
France et pas que par transposition donc
c'est très complexe le mode d'emploi du
zan parce que
0 artificialisation
il faut plus consommer le terrain comme
on l'a fait par le passé et
environnemental on le comprend très bien
on le commandant sauf que vous nous avez
dit il y a de plus en plus de Français
qui veulent vivre dans les dans les
métropoles et dans les dans les
centres-villes ici on peut pas si on
peut plus artificiellement le
haut-commissaire aux plantes qui est
aussi secrétaire général du CNR à donner
des exemples très concrets il a dit mais
il faut qu'on apprenne mère promoteur
constructeur à faire cette sobriété
foncière on sait le faire on s'est
utilisé des surfaces imperméabilisées
des parkings qui sont déjà
artificialisés vont s'en servir
on attend de voir de combien sera
abonder le le fond friche mais il est
dans les mesures il est dans les mesures
à juste titre surélever les immeubles ça
a été cité aussi par François Bayrou
bien sûr qu'il faut le faire on y est
tous réticents même mouvement h ne le
fait pas autant Dieu sait si les
immeubles nationales architecture
allemand le permettent bon voilà donc
tout cela il faut aujourd'hui il faut
une production forte et les
investisseurs quand vous dites que on va
vers une France davantage de locataires
vous avez raison dans les années qui
viennent de toute façon beaucoup
n'arriveront pas à acheter il faut pas
leur mentir donc il va falloir une offre
locative et les tensions que bien ici ou
d'autres sites identifient elles sont
insupportunes il va falloir que
fiscalement on donne envie et il y avait
une demande d'un statut je dirais à la
fois stable
séduisant parce qu'on pourrait amortir
le bien parce qu'on pourrait déduire
davantage les charges il faut donner
envie au ménage d'acheter des logements
pour les louer aux autres c'est clair
Mathieu j'ai juste une question parce
que en janvier on a appris qu'il y avait
3 millions de logements vacants en
France et le double de 20 ans alors je
sais que c'est pas si simple il y a des
logements qui sont en mauvais état que
il y en a qui sont fréquents pour faire
certains temps mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait
de ça peut-être un mot parce qu'elle est
belle la dessus et ensuite je vous donne
la parole en fait ce qui se passe c'est
qu'il y a quand même des mouvements de
population qui sont
[Musique]
une réponse ça a été dit par le par
l'exécutif c'est la vérité il n'y a pas
que la construction neuve alors je
reviens tiens sur le cet objectif 0
artificialisation nette
en 2030 David Amiel et je repose un peu
la question de la comment on peut
conjuguer l'impératif environnemental et
la demande croissante de logement dans
notamment dans les dans les grandes
villes de choses d'abord il y a toute
une part qu'on peut faire qui évidemment
dans les grandes villes comme d'ailleurs
dans des villes moins grandes qui est de
reconvertir bureau en logements friche
vous l'avez dit ça fera partie du fond
friche de reçoit des friches
industrielles peut-être demain des
friches commerciales dans les centres
orientent il y a également la question
de la densification et la question de la
réhabilitation lourde ça fait partie des
choses qui ont été justement annoncées
aujourd'hui par le gouvernement
c'est-à-dire que vous avez beaucoup de
logements sociaux qui souhaitent aller
plus loin dans ce qu'ils appellent la
seconde vie du bâtiment c'est à dire
d'avoir quelque chose d'intermédiaire
entre de la construction neuve ou de la
rénovation ça a des rénovations
extrêmement lourdes mais qui permettent
pour le coup de rejeter un bâti pour une
cinquantaine d'années et puis vous avez
la question de la rénovation thermique
des logements énergétiques d'ailleurs à
la fois des maisons des appartements et
là pour le coup c'est un immense
chantier qui est devant nous il se
trouve que la semaine dernière j'ai eu
l'occasion à l'assembler de faire un
salon de propositions pour accélérer
parce que je crois qu'effectivement
c'est un défi majeur pour la planète
pour la soirée énergétique pour le
pouvoir d'achat un peu plus tard
notamment de ma prime rénove et des
effectivement de l'enjeu n'est pas sur
thermique mais je voudrais
Mathieu qu'on s'intéresse ensemble à ce
conseil national de la
refondation
c'est vrai que celui-ci était consacré
au logement il y en avait plusieurs qui
étaient prévus sur différentes
thématiques c'est quoi l'objectif de ce
CNR c'était une nouvelle méthode est
promis le président bon c'était jamais
que la quatrième fois en 5 ans mais
cette fois-ci on allait voir ce qu'on
allait voir un processus inédit
décentralisé moins vertical pour cette
clé à la fois au défi de moyens et long
terme et aujourd'hui d'avenir
structurant alors il y a un an quasiment
jour pour jour donc Ouest-France le
président fraîchement réélu livré les
ingrédients de qualifié à l'époque d'une
révolution culturelle et même trouver un
très beau nom pour ça Conseil national
de la refondation l'acronyme CNR comme
le Conseil National de la Résistance et
il disait avec les forces politiques
économiques sociales associatives des
élus des territoires et de citoyens
tirés au sort on va se donner plusieurs
mois pour identifier les besoins et
bâtir des projets en sortira une feuille
de route et des moyens chiffrés
n'insister plusieurs fois sur la
question des moyens les Français sont
fatigués des réformes qui viennent d'en
haut ils ont plus de bon sens que les
circulaires Paris doit être au service
du terrain un an plus tard on fait le
bilan alors il y a des chantiers qui ont
été lancés c'est vrai sur des
thématiques aussi variées que le bien
vieilli en la santé l'école le numérique
la jeunesse je sais pas tous et donc le
logement tient pas les retraites
justement c'était une des questions que
lui poser les syndicats à la rentrée
dernière ça fonctionne souvent à bas
bruit ça fonctionne sur les territoires
il y a eu beaucoup de de réunions
notamment sur les questions d'école ou
le santé mais on attend encore faut-il
avouer la lumière de ce qui reste pour
beaucoup de ces détracteurs une sorte de
machin supplémentaire il faut dire que
le CNR c'est d'abord heurter une forme
de boycott à la fois de de syndicats
d'un certain nombre de syndicalistes
comme la CGT par exemple ou de nombreux
élus des oppositions les uns comme les
autres ils voyant au mieux un gadget au
pire une tentative de contournement des
instances existantes de discussion et
notamment du Parlement souviens que
Gérard Larcher enfin beaucoup de gens
avaient dit c'est un contournement du
Parlement et pour les Français et pour
les Français le CNR reste très très mal
connu personne ne sait ce que c'est et
même pour la majorité c'est une forme
d'OVNI la façon dont les conclusions du
scénario logement ont été reporté d'un
mois le mois dernier pour des raisons
d'agenda montre le peu de cas que
l'exécutif fait du CNR me disait un
député Renaissance pas vous je précise
récemment et ça crée des déceptions oui
alors comme on le voit pour le CNR
logement d'une certaine façon encore une
fois beaucoup de participants et vous
n'êtes pas les premiers à nous le dire
on l'a même eu sur ce plateau on
souligné la qualité des débats la
diversité des thématiques abordées en
disant c'était c'était une vue assez à
360 sur le sujet
comme souvent c'est la traduction
politique qui est mise en cause ou qui
pêche et on le voit un peu ce soir avec
des interrogations de beaucoup de
professionnels ce qui disent tout ça
pour ça c'est un petit peu comme la
convention citoyenne pour le climat
d'une certaine rénale d'une certaine
manière et en fait sans doute y a-t-il
un problème d'articulation entre
démocratie participative et démocratie
représentative qui n'a pas été réglé
elle est partie sans les participants
sont souvent déçus dans ce type de de de
d'organisme de voir leur proposition par
entreprise en entier ou parfois rester
l'être morte les élus de leur côté sont
parfois agacés de voir que des gens font
le boulot à leur place c'est un risque
de conception imposé sans doute par le
pouvoir d'en haut pour se réconcilier
avec la France d'en bas tout ça sentait
quand même forcement une vieille ficelle
peut-être plutôt qu'une nouvelle méthode
vous y avez participé en république
Cazaux effectivement vous nous dites que
enfin est-ce que vous dites un décalage
entre la qualité de ce qui est ce qui a
été échangé et et le le premier rendu
puisque j'ai compris que c'était une
étape en cette fin d'après midi ça
défilé très clairement dans cet univers
il faut savoir que il y a des gens de
l'univers HLM ne parle pas volontiers et
réciproquement à ceux du logement privé
ceux de la construction à se desservice
faut le dire ça et bien là j'ai vu des
personnes se rencontrer apprendre à se
connaître bon moi j'ai la chance après
35 ans d'en connaître beaucoup mais je
voyais se former comme ça des dialogues
bon ça a été très respectueux de qualité
en visio parce que c'est un peu
l'habitude de comprendre et ça je trouve
que ça appauvrit si on continue à
travailler j'espère qu'on fera mieux le
constellational habitat est passé à des
réunions physiques désormais c'est
beaucoup plus riche mais il y a quand
même malentendu de départ et je trouve
que ça crée une difficulté aujourd'hui
dans CNR il y a le il y a le R de
refondation ça veut dire que tout ce qui
devait être fait depuis 20 ans 30 ans
qui n'a pas on va pas la distribuer les
indulgences il y a pas été fait et c'est
pas juste le président Macron c'est
prédécesseur n'ont pas fait non plus
tout ce qu'il fallait passons il y a eu
des bons mise du logement bref le solde
n'y est pas on refonte ça veut dire
revisiter la fiscalité la question
foncière qu'on évoquait si aujourd'hui
on prend des bonnes décisions on enverra
les faits dans 5-6 ou 7 ans si des
terrains arrivent il faut avoir les
construire bon ça c'est du travail de
fond
il faut le commencer à un moment donné
et puis ce secteur c'est tellement
dégradé depuis même la mise en place en
novembre du CNR que ça relève de
l'urgence et là il y a mal entendu on
est sur quel terme
d'urgence quand le président dit ce
n'est pas en temps de crise chez vos
confrères de challenge qu'il faut tomber
le moteur ben aussi il faut à la fois
traiter la crise voilà la panure jante
qui voulait sur le bord de l'autoroute
et puis il faut tomber le moteur il faut
le concevoir il faut faire les deux le
CNR avait les deux missions et je pense
que même dans les rapports rendus ça a
pas été très clair david-amel votre avis
là-dessus peut-être pas seulement sur
celui du logement mais est-ce que c'est
on n'a pas la une machine à fabriquer de
faux espoirs finalement le Seigneur il a
une double dimension c'est le pari à la
fois de réfléchir de dialoguer de
travailler ensemble c'est ce que vient
d'expliquer monsieur et puis il y a
aussi le pari de faire ensemble c'est à
dire qu'il s'agit non seulement de
construire des propositions des
diagnostics mais il s'agit de pouvoir
aussi mettre en commun ensemble des
projets c'est ce que disait monsieur
croissanto il y a beaucoup de choses qui
se font au sens le plus propre du terme
fer à bas bruit c'est particulièrement
le cas dans l'éducation nationale moi
j'ai vu dans ma circonscription des
lycées en l'occurrence des lycées
professionnels à enseignement adapté qui
se sont lancés dans une vraie dynamique
pour construire un projet à
l'établissement pour tisser des
passerelles avec d'autres institutions
du quartier et c'est tout ce travail là
qui est important qui n'est
effectivement peut-être pas assez mise
en lumière ça dépend pas uniquement du
gouvernement évidemment mais je crois
que c'est ce travail là qui est
important alors bien sûr c'est des
méthodes nouvelles donc par définition
il y a des choses à améliorer des choses
à réfléchir une fois que ça le mérite de
faire le mérite de faire dialoguer
j'ai pas entendu beaucoup de
professionnels de de l'immobilier du
bâtiment donner insatisfait site
au gouvernement à l'issue de de
ce CNR donc il y a quand même un
décalage entre les espoirs qui sont nés
d'une telle mécanique et les mesures
annoncées non mais ce qui est vrai ce
que disait aussi monsieur d'ailleurs
c'est que la question du logement pour
toutes les raisons d'ailleurs qu'on a
des vertus depuis le début créer
énormément d'attentes parce que c'est un
sujet qui légitimement pose énormément
de questions et un défi nageur donc bien
sûr qu'il y a des étapes et quand les
étapes sont bons partiel comme c'est le
cas aujourd'hui bah forcément ça peut
créer cette tension là mais je crois que
l'essentiel c'est effectivement de
pouvoir continuer dans les mois à venir
à avoir cette dialectique de dialogue et
puis surtout à pouvoir porter des
réponses à tous les niveaux de cette
crise alors je voudrais qu'on fasse un
focus là maintenant sur les le prêt à
taux zéro puisque ça fait partie des
annonces qui ont été faites par
Elisabeth borne à l'issue de ce CNR
logement et le ministre du Logement
Olivier Klein il a anticipé ce matin il
était sur France Info il annonçait le
maintien sous certaines conditions
maintient dans le neuf
on le maintient dans le neuf et c'est
très important dans le collectif 9 ça
fait en zone tendue ça va permettre
vraiment de nombreux Français d'avoir
cette espèce d'apport c'est un prêt à
taux zéro c'est à peu près considéré
comme pour la banque comme un apport on
va le maintenir dans le l'ancien en zone
tendue et détendue parce que on parle
beaucoup des passoires thermiques le
moment de l'acquisition c'est le bon
moment pour faire les travaux et donc
permettre de sortir des appartements qui
sont vacants grâce au prêt à taux zéro
et un soutien à l'acquisition c'est
vraiment extrêmement vertueux donc non
c'est 600 millions d'euros par an que le
nouveau PTZ va dépenser pour les
importante alors il y a deux aspects il
y a neuf on y reviendra et puis il y a
les pasteur thermique parce qu'on l'a
déjà évoqué je voudrais qu'on y consacre
un peu de temps de de Pascal avec vous
parce qu'elle est belle
rénovation des partiels c'est presque la
même question que sur le
l'artificialisation net CRC urgence
écologique mais avec des effets pervers
notamment à risque d'effet dominos sur
les loyers on voit qu'il y a pas mal de
de
propriétaires aux revenus modestes qui
peuvent pas faire les travaux ou ceux
qui font les travaux ils vont le
répercuter sur les loyers donc on est
dans un effet domino là aussi oui tout à
fait d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que le
marché aussi c'est tarif c'est que
finalement pour vendre il vaut mieux
être en lettres A B C D puisque tout ce
qui sera EFG et on pourra plus notamment
le louer ici plusieurs étapes avec
plusieurs étapes donc en fait ça tend le
marché parce qu'en fait tous les biens
qui sont en rénovation qui ont besoin de
rénovation énergétique les prix baissent
donc les gens les vendent pas ils
attendent ils se demandent ce qu'il faut
faire et donc ça ça aussi on aurait dû
le faire il y a 10 ans ah bah bien sûr
c'est ce programme une
urgence et il faut dérèglementation
sinon on changera rien et en effet on
peut on peut penser que tous les
propriétaires qui ont des logements qui
qui veulent louer ils vont être obligés
de faire des investissements et donc
forcément à un moment donné ils vont
dire si on peut pas augmenter les loyers
ils vont se désengager donc en effet
c'est pour ça qu'il y a il y a tout un
tas de sujets qui arrivent au même
moment ça fait des années qu'en effet on
aurait pu agir mais là aujourd'hui il
faut réfléchir plus globalement et
notamment c'est cette question de d'en
effet de soutenir plutôt que des
immeubles que des maisons on a tous
compris qu'une maison c'est énergivore
et qui c'est vraiment ce qui en terme de
transition écologique il faut pas faire
il faut moins de maison individuelles
donc il faut rendre désirable le fait
d'habiter dans des appartements il y a
pas de raison de ne pas être aussi bien
dans un appartement
des Français préfèrent habiter dans une
maison mais on peut très bien et ça il
faut le faire en effet en expliquant en
fait que finalement ils le savent ils
l'ont bien vu mais le prix l'énergie a
tellement augmenté ils savent bien que
dans une maison c'est très coûteux on ne
les construit pas comme avant il faut
aussi le dire il y a 10 ans la parcelle
moyenne d'une maison était de l'ordre de
3000 mètres carrés elle est aujourd'hui
inférieure à 300 mètres carrés bon sous
l'effet de l'augmentation des prix mais
aussi sous d'autres effets les Français
n'ont pas
besoin de si grand terrain on fait des
maisons mitoine et mitoyennes on fait
des maisons à étage on densifie la
maison individuelle donc cette maison on
la stigmatisé manuel vargon un peu
facilement je la vise pas en disant ça
parce qu'il y a une idéologie
anti-maison individuelle il faut voir
que les constructeurs ils sont les plus
innovants et dans le plan du
gouvernement on remet ça alors du jour
dans la construction
mais est-ce qu'on peut tenir l'urgence
les enjeux d'urgence environnementale en
continuant de construire des maisons
individuelles en français un peu c'est
un peu le débat qui Emmanuel vargon son
temps d'abord et le gouvernement a fini
par le dire 2050 ça n'est pas
aujourd'hui avec une échéance à 2030
division par deux beaucoup de maires
anticipent c'est à dire qu'ils sont ils
sortent les aérophes ils disent où là on
touche plus au terrain au point même que
les plans locaux d'urbanisme sont
utilisés qu'à 65% c'est-à-dire qu'on
pourrait construire plus mais les élus
sont sur les freins donc aujourd'hui
avec des terrains déjà existants et au
prix de l'inventivité avec la sobriété
avec des modes constructifs différents
aussi pour faire baisser les prix à
juste titre le président Macron je crois
veux que les acteurs professionnels se
prennent en main il y a de l'innovation
aussi un maître dans l'histoire on peut
pas le nier on reproduit beaucoup les
modes constructifs du passé on peut
faire mieux évidemment ma prime rénov
vous en parliez tout à l'heure vous avez
vous vous en avez présenté en quelque
sorte le bilan à l'Assemblée il y a
quelques jours il faut encore le faire
évoluer est-ce qu'il est trop compliqué
suffisamment accessible notamment aux
ménage aux revenus les plus modestes ben
vous avez tout dit ça que la rénovation
énergétique elle est indispensable elle
est indispensable pour tenir nos
émissions de réduction de gaz à effet de
serre et il est indispensable pour
soutenir aussi notre souveraineté
énergétique on en a assez parlé ces
derniers mois alors pour aller plus loin
il y a plusieurs leviers le premier
c'est qu'il faut effectivement donner
aux gens les moyens de rénover parce que
si on veut faire des rénovations
globales des rénovations performantes
des lourde ça coûte très cher il va
falloir mettre ça veut dire quoi
davantage de moyens davantage de moyens
budgétaires notamment via ma prime rénov
pour réduire le reste à charge pour les
ménages modestes très modestes encore
plus d'aide pour les mauvaises il faut
aussi pouvoir mobiliser le secteur
bancaire pour aller aider la classe
moyenne qui aujourd'hui n'a pas
suffisamment les moyens pour rénover moi
j'ai fait une proposition
par exemple j'ai fait par exemple cette
proposition qui est de généraliser un
instrument un peu nouveau qui est le
prêt avance mutation l'idée est assez
simple vous empruntez pour rénover votre
logement tant que vous y vivez vous ne
remboursez rien ni le principal ni les
intérêts donc à la fin du mois ça ne
dégrade pas votre trésorerie et c'est
uniquement au moment où vous revendez
que vous remboursez la banque je crois
que ça fait partie des instruments
innovants il y en a probablement
d'autres qu'il faut pouvoir mettre en
oeuvre pour donner à tout le monde les
moyens de s'engager dans cette
rénovation et puis la deuxième chose
c'est évidemment de simplifier
aujourd'hui tous les Français qui se
sont engagés dans les travaux de
rénovation savent à quel point c'est
compliqué aujourd'hui aussi le
gouvernement annonçait des moyens
supplémentaires pour avoir
deux fois plus d'accompagnateurs ce
qu'on appelle mon accompagnateur Renov
pour aider aussi les gens à prévoir leur
financement à programmer leurs travaux
et ça aussi c'est très important pour
pouvoir suivre non aujourd'hui n'est pas
prêt il y a deux parties de cette chaîne
qui ne sont pas aujourd'hui encore
rendez-vous de l'Histoire les
diagnostiquaires immobiliers bon vous
faites les cours régulièrement de
problèmes de fiabilité diagnostic bon
cette filière n'est pas organisée
aujourd'hui il faudrait deux fois plus
de personnes qui en a il y en a 10 000
il en faudrait
il en faudrait le double bon et très
clairement il y a un problème de
compétences il y a pas de filière de
formation elle n'existe pas et les
pouvoirs publics sont en train de s'en
saisir il y a un chantier du Conseil
national de l'habitat là-dessus on s'est
une première fois ce matin à la demande
un autre collègue Lionel cosse
deuxièmement les entreprises en bâtiment
vous savez qu'il faut qu'elle soit
reconnue garante de l'environnement RGE
c'est-à-dire pour pouvoir faire les
travaux en question et pour donner accès
aux aides notamment à ma prime rénov
alors c'est important
on en revient au sujet antérieur il y
avait 15% d'entreprises sur les un peu
moins de 600 000 entreprises en bâtiment
en France qui était RGE
le ministre avait dit le gouvernement
mais on souhaite canner 20 25% en étant
en train de tomber à 10 pourquoi
pourquoi parce que il est difficile et
c'est un peu tatillon plein
administratif de décrocher le label RGE
parce que certains disent que ce crible
n'est peut-être pas la preuve de la
compétence il faut le revoir il faut
accompagner les entreprises en tout cas
de cause la Fédération du Bâtiment la
CAPEB bouge là-dessus mais comment
voulez-vous quand vous ne trouvez pas
les entreprises engager ces travaux
c'est aussi un souci pour les ménages ou
pour les professionnelles immobiliers on
sait qu'il y a des travaux à faire pour
30 40 000 euros qui va les faire de
manière compétente avec des garanties de
gains énergétiques c'est aujourd'hui
c'est encore trop compliqué ma prime
rénov d'après vous ou est-ce que
effectivement
le sujet là-dessus faut pas jeter à la
pierre au point public ma prime rénov
pour moi et très bien conçu c'est une
Inde équitable c'est à dire qu'elle aide
chacun selon ses revenus bon mais par
exemple m'a pris mon offre pour les
copropriétés aujourd'hui ne marche pas
quand vous regardez les statistiques il
a été fait c'est dérisoires quelques
dizaines de ma prime vraiment
copropriété alors que le gros de la
rénovation c'est 200 milliards de
travaux qui font engagés sur les
copropriétés françaises pour les mettre
à niveau énergétique 200 milliards de
travaux en gros dans les 10 ans qui
viennent il y a beaucoup de
propriétaires qui louent à l'intérieur
donc ils sont obligés et bien là-dessus
après brelanque de fonctionne pas on a
des problèmes de fiabilité dans ces
copropriétés diagnostics c'est très
complexe voilà donc ce sont des sujets
auxquels le gouvernement doit vraiment
s'atteler parce que le calendrier ne
sera pas tenu pour des raisons je dirais
mécanique voilà c'est pas que la
destination est mauvaise c'est que il
faut pouvoir y arriver avec le véhicule
en question allez on termine là-dessus
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce à ce débat et à bientôt
sur public Senn